cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com
all right you guys we we know that Joe
is is corrupt but we have to talk about
this this video right here have you guys
seen this one I need I need your help
Joe Biden was giving a speech to the UN
General Assembly and he said some words
I think
and I don't know what he said
I will play the video for you now
I already has the Evolve our
institutions
and drive creative new Partnerships let
me be clear
certain principles are in the National
system are sacrosanct okay I caught some
of that but wow let's try that again
play it again I mean it has the involve
our institutions
institutions something about our
institution something on a shop of
pressure our instance he said let me be
clear and you heard a couple of people
laugh
all right here we go
I already have the involve our
institutions
and drive creative new Partnerships let
me be clear
[Laughter]
okay here we go
now we're gonna have some involve our
institutions and drive creative new
Partnerships let me be clear
certain principles
but it but it also sounds like a yeah I
think it's like are you kidding me kind
of laughs what was I I literally I'm
deaf in one ear so maybe I'm struggling
really hard here but like I have no idea
what the first phrase hey look I
decipher TuneIn pressure habit of
pressure and we think what he was saying
was true International cooperation under
pressure
okay he's also said badakaf care and
next now recent I have no idea what
those things are that's a new uh drug
because they just take a bunch of
letters and throw it together because
every other commercial on TV if you
notice is yet another joke I mean like a
drug yeah but this one with only 47 side
effects this one listen listen
to the involve our institution I
recognize something is that what he's
saying
I really has the involver institution a
reasor is our institutions wow
but look look Mitch McConnell freezes
but it's almost sad
no it is it's sad Mitch McConnell free
Mitch McConnell freezes and then
everyone's like whoa he's not doing
anything it's major news because it's
shocking Biden figured it out mutter
incoherently and what happens is the
journalists are too embarrassed to ask
did I misinterpret what he said so with
you know McConnell paralyzed or whatever
having a stroke or whatever is having
everyone agrees something bad happened
but do you want to be the one person in
the room to go what what did Biden just
say and they're gonna go did you not
hear him I'm not here do your job for
you also people that don't speak English
but some some will but there's got to be
of the 95 of liberal journalists don't
they don't you think someone's guy's
been closed doors going yes or can we
not see the sign language interpreters
like why doesn't one come out of their
closet it's well no no it's because what
happens is these these uh corporate
journalists after Biden gives a speech
and they take notes they walk into the
back room say I have no idea what he
just said so you tell me and then they
they look over over at their CIA Handler
who then says here's the quote and then
they just type whatever whatever they're
told by the Intel agencies there you go
that's that's there you go what is like
the sign language interpreter they have
sign language interpreters of that
events were they just standing there
like what did he say no they probably
just went like this that's the
university
that's a good one that's crazy man this
is the president of the United States
well you're talking about McConnell too
I mean just friends and Feinstein oh my
gosh it's like a horror movie I mean
it's really scary when they wheel her in
I mean it's sad we can talk all about
the cultural decay in this country and
you know the potential for conflict or
whatever's going on but let's just be
real like one of the biggest existential
threats we're facing is our decrepit
aging political class and their their
inability to relinquish any power well
left more than anybody was screaming
about these another old age old guys in
office and who do they put in office I
mean they still voted for the guy yeah I
mean apparently Trump 77 too to be fair
he's old they're all a lot more energy
yeah I I say this like Trump is a fry
you know what I mean no Trump has this
video where he like hits a golf ball up
and then catches it and everyone's like
yeah you know he may be out of shape but
Biden's busted did you see that picture
of Joe Biden stretching and the guy's
like it's Joe Biden stretching before
running and they're like Trump couldn't
do this is
like Trump couldn't do this Joe Biden
does all sorts of stuff I have golf with
President Trump I gotta tell you it's a
pretty good golf ball pretty good that's
pretty good yeah it's an example of how
solar age and genetic age are not the
same like you can go around the Sun a
hundred times and you still have a
healthy youthful body okay
and talk about a guy with a lot of
energy let's let's play this Harry SSN
video I have a lot of things to say
about this guy just out of curiosity for
all the Trump supporters and Republicans
do you think that Donald Trump could do
something like this
what is he doing President Biden was
this is President Biden out in Delaware
recently exercising with first lady Jill
Biden and I saw this photo I was like
wow that's pretty impressive for Joker
yeah you know what and I thought like
that is impressive for you and I agree
anybody really think that Trump could
mash the
and also do these Trump supporters think
that Trump could ride a bike
like can always imagine that and this
photo proves a lot to me not only is Joe
Biden more mentally fit to be president
but he's also more physically fit to be
president you know Republicans always
want to talk about Biden's Fitness for
president truly is liberalism truly is
the sickness but but this is the problem
they want you to say liberalism but it's
not liberalism this is like I I'm sorry
dude look I'm an old man I guess I'm 37.
I wish I was right but when I was
growing up the kid who acted like this
was like the weirdo I don't know what
neighborhood he's from maybe in the
suburbs that's what it's all about like
he would be made he would be the nerd
who would get bullied and if you if that
was the kind of if the way dude I'm just
saying you go to my where where my high
school was I was only there for two
months but if a kid like that was
standing around being like you know but
Bill Clinton was really good you guys
can can George W bush Al Gore is gonna
be alike dude he'd get he'd get picked
on sorry you're a kid why do you care
about I know it's a horrible he's like
20 something oh yeah plus like he's
being paid for it right this is can we
watch the whole bike video like he can't
win my job I didn't fell down right dude
Joe Biden fell up the stairs
how many videos do you got to show up
walking around not knowing where to go
when it gets off of stage speaking or
shaking shaking hands at the air yeah
but I'll just I'll just say this it's
weird that he's like can Trump do this
and I'm like probably not next question
yeah I don't understand what that has to
do with anything I care about yeah man
the conflation between Biden and Trump
anytime someone in a conversation about
Biden brings up Donald Trump or vice
versa talking about Donald Trump and
someone brings up Joe Biden you gotta
not dismiss it but and realize that
that's a moronic conflation of data it
has nothing to do with it I know Hillary
Clinton can do that
makes the fake look even better now
after that video of him playing tennis
with Jake Paul oh right he's like
actually in in pretty good shape so look
I'm not voting for Trump or anybody
based on whether or not they can stretch
their what muscle is that that's the
hamstrings in the back isn't it
yeah I thought I thought that that's
what it was it could be um he might be
doing a sartorial story to decide you
know Sartorius but uh I I really don't
care if Trump can do that I really don't
care if Trump can say Trinidad of
pressure all that matters to me is that
Trump is the one guy with the highest
probability of just firing random people
and and cutting down these bureaucracies
for the longest time Republicans have
been like smaller government smaller
government than they spend more money
they bring more people they don't reduce
the government I'm just hoping that
Donald Trump is a guy who goes in for
revenge and just starts firing people in
which case Harry dude I literally
wouldn't care if Joe Biden did a round
off back layout I would be like wow
that's really cool where do I vote for
Trump it's meaningless Trump trump could
be sitting in a wheelchair eating a box
of Krispy Kremes with icing and custard
all over his face and I would still be
like
guys he's gonna Place more likely to
fire people and that's all I can say I'm
like I'm not happy with any of it hey he
made his energy independent right and
now as soon as Trump I mean as soon as
biting on office he said no we're going
to cut off the oil supply here let's buy
oil from countries that hate us and gas
goes to seven bucks a gallon yeah that's
good don't pay attention to that but
that's that's the point because the
mechanism of the uh American energy or
military I should say the Petro dollar
is we need to be dependent on others so
that they don't stop being customers for
us right the reason we give millions of
dollars to gender studies programs in
Pakistan is so that they have money to
spend so that they spend it it's really
that simple you give the money to
someone Pakistan is a choice they could
trade in one or they can trade in
dollars so we go to them say hey we're
gonna give you 12 million dollars for
gender studies I don't care what you do
with it and then they're gonna they're
gonna pad their their bank accounts
they're gonna steal that money but that
ensures that they're going to be like no
no we trading dollars
so when China comes to them and says no
no trading dollars trade in in one
they're gonna be like oh he's got 12
million dollars if we keep trading in
this we're rich for free screw off
that's that's the name of the game so
when Joe Biden gets in he has to shut
down Donald Trump's make America great
plans because what Donald Trump is doing
oh he's bringing manufacturing back he's
securing our borders he's making us
energy independent so that we can have a
good economy here people like Joe Biden
and the Deep State establishment
whatever you want to call it they want
Global control they want war they want
Conquest they want unipolar Global power
so they're going to say no no no we got
to give more of American resources away
to ensure that people are beholden to us
is this this might seem like a stupid
question is it one of those things where
like if we're uh with the us being so
involved militarily in other countries
uh is part of our involvement uh helping
other countries with our military is
part of that under the expectation that
they will continue to trade in US
dollars
well yeah of course yeah uh Ukraine for
instance Biden threatened to withhold a
1.3 million dollar loan from the IMF
billion billion 1.3 billion yeah that's
what I meant to say thank you um what
was happening is the IMF was going to
loan it to the Ukrainian government and
the U.S was going to
um what are they called back it say like
if they if they default we'll pay it and
then Biden was like we're not going to
back it if you don't fire Victor shoken
and they're like well uh off oh sir
pardon me and then so then he was like
no it's I'm serious and so they fire
Victor it's crazy when I was watching
that clip because uh even my assessment
of the barisma Scandal is nowhere near
as in depth as that guy's assessment was
when he's breaking it brilliant Rob
knower is his name they they mycolas
lachevsky's funds were frozen under this
encryption investigation and the
government passed some provision that
unfros them and Shook and immediately
rushed in to get his asses Frozen again
because they were going after him Joe
Biden comes in says fire the prosecutor
they they they didn't fire him out right
he ended up getting or he was forced to
resign somewhat later on I think it was
a few months later and then the new guy
who comes in that bites again he's solid
new guy clears launches give all
wrongdoing acids are unfrozen slachevski
returns to Ukraine to begin his work
once again
Donald Trump gets elected starts
investigating what Joe Biden did
zlachevsky flees Ukraine once again yup
these people are evil corrupt
individuals that would sell out their
own mothers look at what Hunter Biden is
Joe Biden made him that and uses him as
some vessel to squeeze resources out of
his public career evil yeah it's just so
so despicable it is man where were you
Kevin when in 2015 when this was kind of
transitioning into the Trump years right
what was it like were you in Hollywood
at the time yeah yeah we left about five
years ago so I was definitely still
there thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time